comment regardez regardez ces images
c'est invraisemblable
je vais retourner au rez de chaussée
afin que vous compreniez le progrès
ainsi tout va bien vous aurez français
à domicile donne sur une rue passante
comme vous le voyez nous sommes en plein
après midi de nos jours et bien a priori
rien d'irrégulier dans ses ouvrages
voici merci merci et vous passez tous
les mercredis dans se rendre au marché
s'ils s'arrêtent dans le bistrot vadam
merci encore le tir et des oreilles n'a
rien de plus a montré ici connaissait ce
genre de paysage
à présent je vais retourner à l'état
vous constaterez venir le phénomène
il avait vérifié la fenêtre arrière sait
jamais le jardin est bien toujours
fidèle à lui même il faudra payer s'est
éteinte à son abattage maintenant si
vous le voulez bien
c'est bien c'est toujours là parfois
cela ne dure que quelques minutes
il ya deux jours j'ai observé ce
phénomène pendant plus d'une heure même
lorsque j'ouvre la douce versus
et son sens différent et qu'avant
qu'est ce que ça fait changement
ces gens sont vraiment étrange tout
s'efface je m'interroge sur l'époque à
laquelle je pense qu'il s'agit de
futures
les années 1950 sera croire
moi c'est un champ au mois riche en
existe toujours
au caire que ces gens aient quelque
chose à quoi se rapprochent déjà verbal
accordé
regardez moi cette année alors moi ce
n'est pas la leur
quel âge aurait en 1950 4e rang j'aurai
un parent troisième rang
j'ignore si je me trouve toujours dans
ma rue qui aurait changé de forme
aussi j'ai été déplacée en un tout autre
angle dans tous les cas la densité
urbaine me semble bien plus important
voilà à vrai dire je ne sais même pas
qui montrer ces images je ne pense pas
avoir besoin dans ce film est davantage
la face à temps
attends mais si je montais à la petite
lucarne des grognes
non cette fois c'est trop pour moi c'est
non
notre hôtel
j'arrête vous trouverez ces images fait
pareil